hi I got some requests to do a tutorial
on foliage now I think this is too broad
of a subject to cover in one video so in
this video I'm going to focus on three
lines and forests that you can have
around your rollercoasters paths scenery
pretty much anything and I'm going to
keep it to one climb it's the most
common climate probably that is that you
find in northern Europe and North
American areas where you know most of
the theme parks are located that people
usually like to build on roller coaster
second three and first I'm just going to
show how I normally do it and then
afterwards we'll look at some examples
and that's how this video will just roll
and when it comes to foliage like this
what I mean is generally you have a
forest around your park but sometimes
just around one roller coaster and
that's kind of what I want to show how I
usually do this it's sort of made up of
three steps the first step is to create
a basic tree line the second step is to
add the normal trees that you would see
that kind of function as the forest
looking trees and the third step is the
infamous ground shrubbery now what I
mean with three lines is wait one issue
in roller coast I can three is that you
sometimes see this enormous green
playing and even those little background
Hills that I took currently have turned
on don't really look too amazing and
they're kind of emergent breaking so
what you want to do is you want to have
this enormous green plane to be
invisible and it isn't exactly realistic
since a normal forest we just have loads
of trees and not really as much of grunt
robbery as you would have it in roller
coaster cone 3 but since you can't build
an entire forest without spending hours
on that you kind of have to cheat the
system
a tiny bit and I would actually
recommend doing it like that since it
does save you time but yeah I'll skip to
what we're actually going to do here
usually I take the hickory tree and just
kind of lower like this place it from a
well small distance from the track it
really depends on where you want your
forests to start but I usually like to
keep a few trees next to the track as
well so a distance like that is usually
good and make sure that if you look at
its you don't really see what's behind
it and this is what's going to keep you
from seeing the empty green grassy
plains that we have in the game and
don't worry if it looks terrible at this
stage this is all going to be covered in
such a way that it doesn't look as
unrealistic anymore some people like to
use the matte sugar maple for this since
it is slightly smaller and if you have
some smaller foliage in general it works
better and on the other hand if you have
larger foliage I would suggest going for
the normal sugar maple since as you can
see this is a really large tree so you
can pretty much block the entire view
with this the only reason why I don't
really like to go with this one is as
you can see it's got a slightly less
dark and less detailed textures so I
always like to go with the Hickory and
then I guess that is the tree line and
that is pretty much how that works then
after that you can kind of fill in the
forest in a way that you want it to be
and this really comes down to your
opinion or whatever type of look you
want to go for and it doesn't really
matter as long as you keep it to a
couple of trees some people like to
spend many many trees at the same place
but even though I would suggest using as
many trees within one Park as you can
don't use too many trees in one place
since it just kind of looks unrealistic
and no real Park is going to put all
that effort into that foliage on the
side of the park I really just feel like
going for the Sycamores over here in my
opinion gardening 2.5 is the set with
the best-looking trees for this kind of
thing though and sevens what's called
ornamental trees is also a really good
set it really just comes down to what
you like most but yeah at this point you
kind of just want to fill in the basic
scenery in a way that you want to have
some simple trees that we can later at
the Grunch rubbery to I might want to
add a base wood really sure about that
yeah that actually looks pretty good and
there this is kind of like the way that
I usually like to build foliage and that
I think is also the best way to do it
but like I said there is no given sort
of tree that you need to use or certain
combination
you need to make it really just comes
down to what you think looks best and
works best but make sure that it doesn't
look too dense so that you don't place
too many trees next to each other but
also make sure that you don't see what's
behind it that's the most important
thing because having that enormous green
plane behind it and being able to see
that as really immersion braking one
thing that I always like to get is
station I mean spices trees even though
this is one of the oldest foliage sets
out there it actually is still pretty
good and I always like to have some
birch trees on the outside of my forest
and really just a bit of an opinion
right there I just think these looks
these look pretty cool and another
really good sets is like I said
ornamental trees has got some really
good stuff in here
these trees are really large so if you
want to have a really high tree line I
would say go for these trees but I don't
think they really fit too well over here
so right now I already have three types
of trees placed within this spot and I
would say about four or five different
types of trees just to make up the basic
three line is what you'd want to have
not any more than that so I think I'm
gonna add just one extra tree see what I
can do with that um yeah let's see
actually I might not want to do that
no I'll just keep it like this and you
don't really have to worry about it
looking too repetitive
at this stage since I think the
different types of ground shrubbery is
what's going to make this look it's on a
bit less boring so I would say some more
base woods should finish this off pretty
well there we go
and at this point it still looks pretty
boring
like there is nothing to look at at the
ground and I would dare say actually
that the ground shrubbery is the most
important part of the entire foliage
Department so it's time to get into that
stuff when it comes to this though you
might you might have noticed that I like
to start off with the big things and
then start doing the small things this
is mainly because it is best if you kind
of work around it that way so that you
can place the ground shrubbery after
you've already placed the other elements
like the larger trees so you can place
the Grunch rubber around that
accordingly but when it comes to ground
shrubbery it's
self I would always suggest starting off
with the largest things and then working
your way up to the smallest things the
last of which is going to be the grass
but okay I'll get into that later now
something that some people can actually
recognize my kind of foliage style for
is the fact that I always like to place
these large trees around the sides I
mean these large trees around the sides
I don't know I just kind of like those
things little blue blue spruce over here
don't want to place too many of these
things don't want it to look like a
miniature pine forest and that's like
the bigger things now one thing that I
really really like is this thing it is
not exactly a fern but many forests have
is they have many ferns basically on the
ground and even though this isn't
exactly a fern it does kind of emulate
it's in a way and I'm pretty sure it is
a type of fern just not the exact type
of it I'm basically I'm really like
icing here so I always like to place
these on the sides and what this does is
you basically don't see that we're three
line as well anymore like if you really
pay attention to it you can see that
it's there but you don't really notice
it anymore
but it still keeps you from seeing that
empty grassy plain behind all this so
yeah I kind of like placing these I
would say though if you play stuff like
this do use different heights because as
you can see if you use too many at the
same height it starts looking very not
so organic in a way so kind of way to
have a little bit of variation and
that's hard to really see it though
there we go
I would like to lower this one as well
and that should be about fine over there
there we go
and that just kind of creates a little
nice tree line like that still
definitely not done with the crown
shrubbery though there is a lot of
variation you can use for this I'm not
going to go into that in the in this
tutorial but I would say just get as
many as you can just get as many sets as
you can and just kind of experiment with
these smaller shrubs that are in there
there aren't any really small shrubs
into gardening 2.5 however there is some
really amazing stuff in
this set for example the apple trees can
be lowered and be a small bush like that
which is a lot another tip that I would
like to give if you can't find the exact
bush that you're kind of looking for
something that I commonly like to do is
just take a tree and lower it until it
looks like a bush and this actually
works surprisingly well and so far it
hasn't really disappointed me too much
now I would like to have a couple of
slightly larger shrubs in here so I'd
like to get ornamental shrubs for that
take either the asian moon or the
honeycomb for that get a tiny bit of
color into this area as well I always
like to place those things and yeah
Asian moon should be fine too there we
go
that works alright and let's see it
could be a little bit more variation in
here like this ferns all over the place
might want to remove a couple to see how
that looks tiny bit of variation in
ground shrubbery because like I said
having too much variation and different
types of trees and combinations when it
comes to like the higher foliage isn't
really the best thing to have but when
it comes to the ground shrubbery that's
just a perfect thing so yeah that's what
I would say have as much of variation in
the ground robbery as you can but keep
it limited for the trees and now it all
just comes down to what you can find and
what you can what you think looks good
you can kind of just place these things
and when you're done with all that
smaller shrubbery one very important
step that actually makes a lot of
difference is to get PB and J's beech
van set and this set has some grass in
it and we're not going to use this as
actual gross I've seen some people try
that I think but it doesn't really work
too well since it's not a realistic
cross set and it is just well beach
grass anyway but it does work amazing as
a foliage blender since what it
essentially kind of does is when you
look at the foliage right now it's just
really in a straight line you just have
no foliage over here but then suddenly
over here there's all types of foliage
and a really dense forest like that and
we kind of don't want the transition to
be that harsh so I always like to place
these things kind of around
with the larger big lush ones just kind
of within the forest and then just kind
of add some mediums around that to you
know start off with the really large
ones in the forest and then just kind of
slow it down with some really small ones
at the end and for that I always like to
take the lush sparse and then just kind
of scatter that around this area and as
you can see it really makes the forest a
lot less harsh and just kind of adds a
transition from the empty cross into the
forest that we have over here one
important one in very important thing
when it comes to Graham shrubbery is to
keep it in clusters don't place your
ground shrubbery in a very in a very
grid like way everywhere but just close
through some ground strawberry here in
there and keep some more empty areas in
between nuts and it's bound to look a
lot that's a lot more natural so
something like that I think looks pretty
good still a couple of large grass
things that I kind of want to get rid of
since as you can see it does have a very
light texture so for that reason I
always like to keep it very limited as
well when it comes to those really large
Ross clusters something like that looks
slightly better yeah and this isn't
really the most realistic looking thing
like I said but as you can see it is
really a very narrow tree line but when
you look at it from the side it looks
like there's an enormous forest over
here and that's basically why this kind
of works now just like over here you
know sometimes you have these very small
areas where you would like to have a
tree or two but there's no room for
anything else it kind of works in the
same way except you don't have to use a
three-line never ever use a three-line
in the middle of your park where you're
bound to notice it since that is also
quite emotion breaking so for this thing
right here just in the middle of your
park if you have one small spot where
you wanna have some simple foliage just
take like the type of tree that you want
to have over there
I would say that's a black locust can
actually work quite nice over here or
this thing probably this thing yeah so
that thing over there and then hmm I
don't know what I would want to have
next to that's feeling like there's
still a tiny bit of space that I can use
here it's got spices to use for that
and get some simple well just a bird
section over here that should work fine
actually no I already have many poachers
over here let me remove some perches
over there a perch by the way is a tree
that you should use sparingly it's not
like you can make forests out of that
and yeah over here same deal start off
with the large shrubbery and work your
way down to the very smallest shrubbery
like the very small patches of grass
like that so I'd like to have some apple
trees around this like that though
slightly higher there we go
and no flowers by the way stuff like
this is not where you can randomly add
flowers flowers is something that I
would like to make a future video about
but just as a heads up right now don't
place flowers in the middle of nowhere
unless they are flowers that can grow in
the wild since you have to maintain
those things and this doesn't really
look like the place where you would
regularly maintain flowers so keep your
flower usage - next to the paths and not
in the middle of a forest like I said
unless it looks like a flower that can
grow in the wild something like this
it's really hard to judge that but
something like this could work in the
middle of a forest but the tulips
wouldn't really work okay so in any case
I should have some larger shrubbery over
here I think I can just get ornamental
shrubs for that again I haven't really
used this thing yet and it should work
alright there we go was one awesome
thing as well is probably to get some
lodges around this thing let's see some
of these and I always like to lower
these so you have some very very small
pine trees next to it and at this point
I feel like that's actually good enough
to start mixing some shrubbery that is
after I gets maybe like one phone yeah
there we go
and it's time for some beet sauce and
then we should be done around here
just a tiny bit of big large beach cross
and some medium lush shrubs just kind of
run that but really keep it to a minimum
and some very small lush spice ones
because I always like to use those to
kind of blend that in and that should be
good
one last touch that I also like to add
whenever you have an area where there
isn't as much foliage as kind of around
that area I always like to get some tiny
bit of dirt in there let's see with this
work that's kind of light say something
like this would be better just some very
slight variations in the ground texture
not really a foliage thing but I would
like to get that in when you have an
area that's completely empty and devoid
of much other foliage so that's it for
doing basic foliage and like I said
there are many different combinations of
trees that you can use and it really
depends on what you think looks best for
your specific color or area but this is
kind of the basic way that I like to
work around it one other thing that I
like to do usually is after it's all
done look at the tree line and see if
there's not anything that I can kind of
want to remove since it looks a tiny bit
dense like over here there's a tree over
here that I think is just a little bit
too much tiny bit dense over here like
to remove that one as well
and with that I'm feeling like it looks
a tiny bit better also I like to keep my
tree lines a tiny bit dynamic don't just
make them completely straight three
lines and don't just have forests with
just trees
there are always some kind of curves
where the tree line either curves or
where you have some larger open spaces
within the forest but that's really
something to kind of mess around with I
think it's a good time to start looking
at some example of ollege alright so
this was my Christmas special coaster
but even though this is an a completely
different climate very northern climate
which means that you have these very
large pines with ice stems and things
like that
these still the still the same basic
principle of making the foliage works
over here and if you zoom out you can
kind of see that since even though it is
really just Pines over here behind all
of this foliage we have the
same basic tree line over here with old
Spice's trees and before that we have
the larger trees over here and the
ground shrubbery actually using the same
Bush over here next to the rollercoaster
and even though this is not a very large
tree line that owns really that many
trees before the antique grassland
starts nowhere in this entire coaster
can you see those empty grasslands
behold behind all of these trees so
that's kind of how that works as you can
see even though I took different trees
for this and different shrubs it still
works in the same way and it was also
built in the same way with starting that
tree line around the sides then adding
the larger points to make that realistic
looking forest that you normally have
around the Polo circle and then at the
small grant robbery around the
roller-coaster and that's how that all
works and last but not least an Asian
Park that I'm working on well even
though this is a completely different
climates and yet again used many
different trees it still works in a
similar way since as we kind of look at
the back of this lo and behold there is
the met sugar maples and the Hickory is
behind there and over here we have the
larger trees where actually there is
quite a large amount of trees over here
but that was just because I had some
Japanese stereotypes in my head thinking
I need cherry trees anyway
that's beside the point some larger
trees over here and then it's just close
to this pond and close to the
roller-coaster I have the ground
shrubbery and that's how that all works
so this type of foliage is really not
that hard to do just place the three
lines place the trees in place to go and
shrubbery it doesn't take that much time
but it really looks pretty good until
you look closer and it turns out that it
isn't quite as realistic as you think it
is from the side it looks very realistic
and yeah that's kind of my way of doing
foliage actually that makes it sound
like I came up with all those definitely
not true this is just kind of evidently
the most easy and also poley light way
of doing foliage in rollercoaster going
through that saves time and saves your
computer and looks good in the mean time
so I think this I hope you guys learn
something from this tutorial even
it wasn't as well prepared as I maybe
hoped it would have been and I wasn't
really sure how to exactly do it for
foliage I'll do some future tutorials
and if you have any questions about any
given theme or way of doing it don't
hesitate to ask and I might do a
tutorial on it too in any case thank you
guys for watching and see you guys later